hi I'm Hannah and today I'm reacting to
my craziest mom and progress challenges
pour one out for my terrible roots
Jackson's turning sticks I want him to
decide what he wants to do for his own
birthday now he's turning eight I'm
gonna take the money that I would have
spent on his party and give it to him to
use however he wants for his birthday
I'm like super out of breath for some
reason like I think I was walking and
talking and like didn't know how to time
how you breathe wouldn't do that so for
those of you who don't speak kid he said
he wants to go to Legoland
okay
look what I got all kids look a little
weird in this phase where their big
teeth are coming in and like one is half
out and one is fully out they're like
all crooked and Oh his little perfect
baby teeth are you excited really oh my
gosh he's so little and he always had a
runny nose like for two years of his
life his nose was just constantly
pouring snot and I apparently never
wiped it
[Music]
boogers we have some boogers we just
went away all the first day
oh my gosh we stayed at the hotel and
that was the first time we had stayed at
the Legoland hotel and the kids were so
excited it was very expensive it was a
really big deal and they were just so
excited to go in this elevator
cuz the disco ball drops down from the
ceiling as soon as the doors closed and
music starts playing when the doors open
the disco ball goes away and it's like
the party never happened it's like a
secret elevator party white space we're
in Vegas now so color horse do you want
white brown and Jackson what color horse
black I am NOT going on a horse I went
on a horse he's gonna get his face
painted the way he's talking like the
most iconic Wyatt look of all time
waiting to get his face painted did I
make a meme out of that feel like I
should
[Music]
there is a kid's nightclub inside of
Legoland Jackson I'm gonna get that kid
into classes like just like letting the
milk oh my gosh and now Jackson would
never he would never do that
he's so self-conscious of that stuff he
would never do it I mean how awesome to
have this documentation of my son's
birthday like this is what I appreciate
the most of this series is I have these
memories forever this is not that dry
that's all this tank of jelly dish I had
never seen before
so I was staring at done for a long time
and waiting for them to get fed because
I wanted to see what that looked like
but it wasn't all about 15 minutes in
that I looked down there were plastic
bags and this video was released and I
got a message on Instagram from a woman
being like I work at the aquarium and I
was the person feeding the jellyfish and
I remember you standing by that tank and
I didn't have the heart to tell you that
they were not jellyfish in that tank and
literally called myself out in this
video got called out by somebody who
witnessed it immediately after I didn't
realize that I had been staring at a
display of plastic bags at least I'm
environmentally conscious okay by
Legoland and look what we have here
that's my sister in the middle she's 13
no so Jackson hands me this page ripped
out from a Travel Magazine and look at
once why it was so mad that Jackson got
to hand me the paper oh my gosh this
sass so Wyatt this is where you want to
go
he looks so little his hair has grown
like a good two inches since he looks so
little yes I started to ask each one if
there was an activity they wanted to do
on the way and what about you Jackson so
we found the most amazing spot on the
way to the Grand Canyon it's a rock
waterslide because we're looking for
somewhere for Wyatt it's like a natural
rock waterslide with a pool
yeah I realize know that I was screaming
the whole way down in the moment I
didn't notice and I probably my most
embarrassing things oh my the water was
ice-cold it was like getting into an ice
bath and then I didn't realize as I was
sliding down I was like shrieking the
whole way and so everybody was looking
at me and I didn't get it until after I
got out and my husband was like why were
you screaming and the kids had a blast
it was so cool
so memorable just this place that we'll
never forget
so we went from Red Rock desert we drove
that old RV the RV that we rented was
not new it was like a 90s RV and we
drove it all the way from LA to Sedona
to the Grand Canyon to Vegas back to LA
and I cannot believe that that RV made
it the whole way and there were no
issues look how pretty it was oh my gosh
I want I want to go back do like over
the top beautiful forests mother nature
be slaying us right now I said I still
do that I thought I sounded cool oh my
gosh never knowed it would be this much
beautiful protip don't walk into a dog
pound unless you are fully prepared to
take dog home with you I'll just put
that out there because we
[Music]
I have a dog so when I told my family we
were coming home with a dog they were
literally at our house waiting for us to
pull it in with me why is my arm up that
looks really weird
you got Holmes this is Rosie Rosie girl
or as I like to call her Rose day this
morning I was getting ready for work yes
Jackson was like I want to come I
couldn't think of a reason oh why not
are you guys excited
why are you excited to go to Buzzbee
[Laughter]
he's still there side it ended up being
so much fun but it was really cool first
of all to have everyone I work with me
both of my kids and I was just really
quiet so proud to have these two they're
eating their cereal oh my gosh they
still come to work with me a lot they
just like they're seasoned pros at
BuzzFeed they walk in and they're like
I'm getting a snack mom pie and like
they go to the canteen and get their own
snacks like they know where everything
is they know who everybody is they come
very often and they just like they live
here well-behaved sweet and polite and
respectful kids at work with me that day
it made me realize that they just really
want to know more about me and what I do
and they want to be around me I'm so
grateful to have these videos because
they're such amazing family memories and
if we weren't making this series I know
I would not be documenting things in
this way or that much and just making
sure I have my camera with me to
document these moments there's so much
that I've caught on
camera that I am so grateful to have
because my memory is not that great and
it just captures all of these amazing
family moments that I can look back on
and I'm just baby oh my gosh
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]